[Music]
welcome
to our studio global thank you so much
for tuning in
i'm going to talk today about the things
that we can learn about ggplot2
from our data visualization mishaps
so if you have spent much time
visualizing data you have probably ended
up with some plots
that did not go to plan maybe you had
lots of overlapping blue hexagons
or text that took up the entire area of
the plot
or giant hairballs my name is carawoo
and i'm one of the maintainers of the
accidental art twitter account
and i'm a contributor to ggplot2 also
so i've seen a lot of plots
that have gone totally wrong the
accidental art
account exists to showcase these plots
to showcase the plot's gone beautifully
wrong the things that
uh didn't work out but looked cool
nonetheless
um and i've seen also plots that just
straight up flopped um in sometimes
really subtle
or hard to diagnose ways and so there's
this whole spectrum of
um of messed up plots that that i've
seen
and i know that these can be really
frustrating um
but they can also be an opportunity for
us to create better plots and to
deepen our understanding of the tools
that we use to create those plots
so if you're like me then when you
create a plot
like the one that i the ones that i've
showed
you likely go to a place like stack
overflow
to find someone with a similar problem
find a hopeful solution
and bring that over into your code to
hopefully fix
the problem that you've had and that's
that's great and that's totally
legitimate
i'm going to argue though that when you
get that working solution
it's worth taking the time to think
about how that solution
fits into the conceptual model of
ggplot2
my feeling is that by examining these
messed up plots
that our mistakes generate and how we
fix them we can deepen our understanding
of ggplot2's philosophy
to create better visualizations faster
and more reliably
so what do i mean by ggplot2's
philosophy
dgplot2 is a data visualization package
that embodies a whole theory
of visualization called the layered
grammar of graphics
which is based on leland wilkinson's
grammar of graphics
but it has some specific things that are
um
you know tailored to its implementation
in r
lots of visualization software gives you
a bunch of different charts to choose
from
so you have your pie charts and your
scatter plots and your line charts and
your bar
charts and you take the end result
that you want to achieve and sort of
work backwards to fit your data into it
ggplot2 is not like this ggplot2
is a is a more data first
approach to building visualizations
starting with
you know principles of of essentially a
grammar
for how to convey data in visual form
so when we speak or write we don't
normally
start with a sentence structure that we
want to use
and then fit our message into that
structure
instead we start with some idea and we
use our knowledge of grammar
and syntax and vocabulary to craft the
message we want to express that idea
and that is very analogous to how
ggplot2 works
ggplot2 lets us express our data in
visual forms that
might be totally novel and not fit into
common you know bar charts and line
charts and common types of
types of visualizations this gives us a
really flexible tool
and a really powerful tool that we can
use to create
the intentional art like like you see on
the slide
which was built with danielle navarro's
flametree package
which itself uses ggplot2 so having this
flexibility
gives us a lot of power and control and
it also
opens up room for you know mistakes and
for things to
um not always work out the way we
had in mind the first time around there
are certain
foibles and mistakes that come up a lot
with ggplot2
that demonstrate pretty common
misunderstandings of how
ggplot2 the package works and that's
what i'm going to talk about today
the first one that we're going to talk
about are mapping mishaps
these don't have to do with geographical
maps what we're talking about here is
mapping visual properties in the plot
to variables in our data in the parlance
of ggplot2
this these mappings are called
aesthetics
and they're really at the heart of
ggplot2's grammar of graphics
so let's take this plot this is a plot
of flipper and bill length for different
species of penguins in antarctica
and in this plot we have several
different aesthetics
we have position along the x-axis which
corresponds to flipper length
we have position along the y-axis which
corresponds to
bill length and then we have both color
and shape which correspond to the
penguins species
so one thing that we might want to do
with a plot like this is label these
different clusters we have sort of
well isolated clusters of these data
points and maybe instead of the legend
at the bottom
we want to label those clusters with
what which species they correspond to
and what someone will often do to
achieve this is add a layer to the plot
where they map the text that they want
to appear
to to the x and y
positions where they want to place it so
here we have at x
equals 195 and y equals 55.
we're placing the label chin strap
and you can see that that does work in
that it places
text on the plot if we look closely
though
it doesn't actually look that good um so
it's it's pretty subtle in this example
but the
um the quality of the text is
a little bit pixelated it doesn't look
as good as the points
and lines that are around it
and if we were running this code live it
would actually be a little bit slow to
plot
now it's uh like i said it's a pretty
subtle uh
subtle change uh or a subtle issue but
we actually get a lot of gg plot two
issues opened because of this specific
thing where people run into their um
you know with their own plots that the
plot is really slow that the text looks
really bad and they
come to us to say is this a bug in
ggplot2 like it
why does it look so bad
we can illustrate what's going on here
another way by
using the gg repel package which will
ensure that
text on the plot does not overlap and
when we do that
we can see that we actually haven't just
put a single label on the plot
we've put the whole this whole giant
starburst of
the same text repeated hundreds of times
what's going on here is that we've
actually written our label the same
number of times as there are rows
in our data set in this case 344 times
by putting the text label that we want
inside this aes function
where aes is stands for aesthetics
we've declared a mapping between our
data and the label
causing that label to repeat as many
times as there are
data points so that's not great and
we can avoid this by actually using a
different function called
annotate which is designed to put labels
on plots just once
so it's it's designed to do exactly what
we want to do just
stick that label on there once not map
it to the underlying data
so we tell annotate that we want to
place a text annotation
again give it the position and the label
and it
places that text on the plot for us
and when we zoom in it looks much better
it would be
much faster to plot as well
so that was mapping mishaps where we
misapplied
these aesthetic mappings between visual
elements of the plot
and our data
the next common mix up is what i'll call
scale snafus
in ggplot2 scales convert values from
the data space
to the aesthetic space so in with our
aesthetics that we just talked about
we declared a mapping between visual
elements of the plot and values in the
data
you know shape to species for instance
the scale controls how those data points
get translated
into what we see on the plot
we're going to talk about coordinate
systems too which are what draw the axes
and panels in the plot and generally
kind of set up the 2d environment of the
plot so most plots
including the one that we're using for
our example here
use a simple cartesian coordinate system
but
other plots can use for example like a
geographical coordinate system
or a polar coordinate system in the case
of pie charts
so let's return to our flipper and bill
length
visualization and this time in addition
to the data points i've added
the smooth conditional means for each
species
now let's say that we want to zoom in
this plot to highlight one species
and and sort of focus our attention in
on just one of these areas of the plot
there are two ways that we can
accomplish this one is by setting limits
on the scale
here we're setting the x minimum to 200
and the x maximum
we just let be whatever it normally was
and then the other way that we can
zoom in this plot is by setting limits
on the coordinate system
again setting the x minimum to 200
and letting the x max be whatever it is
when we limit the scale this is the plot
that we end up with
when we limit the coordinate system it
actually looks
quite different the data
looks the same the the individual points
are the same
but the statistical summary looks
drastically different
and that is because when we set the
scale limits
any data that's outside of those limits
will by default be converted to nas
and that this scale transformation
happens
before any statistical summaries so
before we calculate
what those um smooth lines and
error bands look like that data has
already been converted
to nas the coordinate system on the
other hand
um when you set limits there it really
just zooms in the plot so all the other
data
that was originally present
is still is still getting used even
though you can't see it on the plot
so in the first plot where we set the
limits on the scale
statistical summaries look different
because they're
based on just the few data points that
are visible for the species in red and
purple
in the second plot though you can
imagine that all the rest of the data
is still there and it's still getting
used and those smooth lines are
extending out
towards where the rest of the data is
so this is clearly a case where the the
different ways of setting these limits
have have major implications for the
statistical summaries that we're
actually
displaying on the plot
and it's important to know this um so
ggplot2 does alert us to this fact and
if we return
to the code that generated these plots
you can actually see that the former
version will warn you about what's going
on it says
removed 192 rows containing non-finite
values
so so we've gotten this warning message
but it is at times easy to
gloss over these messages or ignore them
and so it's useful to know
how scales and coordinates handle data
that's out of bounds
the last type of ggplot2 mishap that i'm
going to talk about
are issues with themes themed threats
now ggplot2's theme system is not
strictly part of the grammar of
graphics because it really controls all
of the non-data aspects of the plot
whereas the grammar mostly deals with
how we
you know translate our data into visual
form but the theme system is really
important
because it is how you customize a plot
to look exactly how you want it
all the way up from the text font
um and the background color down to
small details like
the length of the ticks on the axes for
example
there are dozens and dozens of things
that you can customize
about plots in ggplot2 but it would be
really cumbersome to have to
specify every single one of those every
single time
so ggplot2 comes with a set of default
themes
that are built in that you can use and
it's a system
for theme elements to inherit
their their values and how they look
from other
aspects of the theme so let's look at an
example
in our theme hierarchy of different
elements that you can customize
text is one of the ones that's way up at
the top
in theory this applies to all the text
elements of the plot
so if we look again at our at our
penguin plot
this plot has a number of different text
elements it has title
it has axis titles and
axis text it has a legend which has some
text on it as well
so all of these are within the umbrella
of text
if you wanted to for example set the
font
of this of all the text in this plot you
would want to do it up at that text
level
rather than having to say i want the
title to be this font and the
axis labels to be this font and so on
at the next level of the hierarchy is
in this example is axis text so we went
from text
down to just the text that labels the
axes
that's everything that is outlined in
blue on this slide
all the axis text elements and and in
this plot we have
axes on the left right and bottom
at the next level of the theme hierarchy
there's axis text
x and axis text y so this allows us
to for example customize the y-axis
while leaving the x-axis alone
and vice versa and there's actually
one more level axis text x bottom
axis text x top axis text y
left and axis text y right try saying
that 10 times fast
where we can customize axes for
potentially on one side of the plot but
not the other
so so these axes can can be on the
bottom or the top or the left and the
right or some combination thereof
and you might want to have really
fine-grained control over
exactly which customizations you're
making so this
this level allows us to do that so so
let's return to our plot so
um again we're looking at these penguin
measurements
and this time i've added a second axis
on the right hand side of the plot
that just duplicates the axis on the
left-hand side
so they're exactly the same and now
let's say that we wanted to customize
this
the the labels on this axis on the y on
our two y axis so that they're maybe
rotated 90 degrees
and right justified so we might write
something like this
to customize both of these axes where
we're setting axis text y
to angle equals 90
h just horizontal justification equals
one
and since we want to apply this to both
of our y axes this seems like
the logical way to do it
but when we look at the plot something
is not quite right
the rotation has taken effect but the
justification has not so only on the
left hand side
are our axis labels right justified
on the right hand side they don't match
so why would why would one of these
changes
take effect but not the other one and
the reason for this has to do with the
base theme that i'm using
so i built the theme for these plots on
the default ggplot theme
theme grey and if we printed out the
whole theme it would be
like super long so so we're not going to
look at all of it but i've just put on
the slide
the the parts of it that have to do with
axis text
you can see that theme gray sets the
margins and the justification
of axis text y and then it actually
adjusts the
adjusts those details for axis text
y right and in particular theme grey is
setting
the justification of text in axis text y
right to zero corresponding to a left
justified
text this brings us to
the crucial piece of the theme system
which is that when you're customizing
theme elements
the most specific element wins if the
theme that you're using
sets a specific element like the
justification
of axis text y right then if you want to
change it
you need to edit that very specific
element and not any of the ones above it
so in our case theme gray sets the
justification but not the angle
of axis text y so when we
change axis text y the justification
that we provided
gets overridden by the theme that we're
using
this is something that has thrown off so
many people it's thrown off me
it's thrown off other contributors to
ggplot
it's it comes up all of the time because
it is a subtle and slightly confusing
aspect of
of how this theme inheritance
inheritance works
but when you think about the fact that
it's working by specificity
and not by the order in which you
uh provide you know customizations to
the theme
it it does make sense so to get a
working plot
we would need to edit axis text y right
like this
so instead of setting our customizations
to the axis text
y element where they'll be overridden by
the theme that we're using we customize
access text
y left and axis text y right and that
makes sure
that our customizations get applied the
way we want them to
and now everything looks good on the
plot
these these two axes are looking exactly
the same on the left and the right
so let's recap the ggplot2 mishaps we've
talked about
we have mapping mishaps where we
accidentally
map the data to a single visual element
over and over and over again
we have scale snafus which is where we
have two different ways of setting the
boundaries of a plot
where one of them discards data one of
them does not
and this can affect the statistical
summaries that are shown on the plot
and we have theme threats where we try
to customize
the plot at a higher level of the theme
hierarchy
that then gets overridden by a more
specific
theme customization we haven't gotten
into all of the components of the
grammar
we haven't talked about um stats geoms
position adjustments in that much detail
but if you really want to get deep into
the understanding of how ggplot2 works
and all of the parts of the
grammar that we haven't covered you
should definitely check out the ggplot2
book
there's a chapter in there specifically
about mastering the grammar
and it will really help you build the
solid foundation for understanding
all these different components of
ggplot2
so i want to leave you with one last
piece of accidental art
it's one of my favorite patterns that
comes up over and over again on the
accidental art twitter
page this sort of weird geometric
pattern
that you often see in maps so here we're
taking data on states
trying to plot it on a map but it's
gotten totally messed up
um so if you don't know what's causing
this error see if you can
find out a fix to it and and think about
whether that fix
tells you anything about how ggplot2
works
um for the purposes of the slide i've
not included the full code
um on this on the on the display
but if you want to see the um the full
code for this plot
as well as all of the other
visualizations that were included in
this talk
have a look at this url and thank you so
much for tuning in
good luck with your future gigi plots
and i hope that you have enjoyed the
[Music]
talk